Về bình kinh mạng hồ giáo yên ràng ngày 18,7 mạng mẹ, nhiều cơ sở nè lượng và biến cản của nước này tụi bị tấn công,
cho bất cảnh tấn thử bực léo thang theo tinh bố của lửa này tấn bộ hạ tân dông mỏ và khi đó,
phù vụ lợi íc của Mỹ và cơ đồng mình cảnh trình đông có thể chở thành một tiêu chung trường hợp yên ràng bị cây hắn.
Thực hi hội đồng anh đến cú gia tôi giao yên ràng Alie, Rajee, Jenny, Trời biết,
Tây Ràng sẽ không lửa bước chứ cơ sức cách của dự và thẳng định,
IWang sẵn sẵn đáp trả những hình đậu mà nước này cho lại đây soại trực tiếp tệ linh của dàng.
Chúc hiểu đó, thức trồng ngoại dời IWang mà Chee Thao ra bật chi cho sang.
Các bình đi của Tây Ràng nhà một bức tự vệ và nhấn mạnh,
nước này mỏ 1 mỏ 1 lận bán như một phần của dài pháp tổng thề,
nhằm chấm rất của dột.
Một số nước vùng vệng cá mỗi IWang tĩnh hành các cuộc tấn công, nhằm vào cơ sở năng lượng trong cuộc vực.
Phía Mỹ vài sở ra tốt đồng linh tiến khẳng định các chiến dịch quan sử hiện nay nhấm năng trạm như mua đe dò ăn nền,
liên quan tự trinh trình tế lượng và gặp cuộc sử của YWang.
Rơ quan sát tình báo, các thẳng đường léo thàn có thể không chỉ gây gián đoạn.
Một con cạo thùng hẳng lớn hơn với 1 quân năng lượng vàng cầu.